c'est un événement d'importance qui
vient de traverser le département des
alpes maritimes avec de fortes
concentrations de pluie des orages
notamment dans tout l'ouest du
département avec les communes de cannes
mandelieu qui ont été énormément touchée
en raison des fortes intempéries et des
risques de circulation demain matin il a
été décidé ici au code centre
opérationnel départemental
la fermeture des écoles des collèges et
des lycées des communes de cannes de
mandelieu la napoule et de pgo marque il
a été décidé que les transports
scolaires de ces établissements ne
fonctionnerait pas
a contrario les autres transports
scolaires ont vocation à fonctionner
puisque il y aura pas eu le même impact
que sur ces communes ce soir